yo this video is brought to you by
square space helping you make beautiful
websites quickly and easily what a dual
y'all this week we get wiped out in the
head with American Psycho by Bret Easton
Ellis
Patrick Bateman is the shallowest
douchebag you've ever seen
he an investment banker at some Swank
firm in Manhattan during the 80s so you
know he said yeah but that show is held
only any work hard my fact all Patrick
do is give his grub on the classy joints
yaffle da bull workout get turnt up in
clubs and worry about how pretty he look
when he's not dunking his girl Evelyn's
calls hollering that other ladies and
getting buck wild with him Patrick all
about his other hobbies murdering people
don't matter who it is what they do
Patrick gonna go stuff and when he do
it's like he ain't even trying to hide
it
fool carry your body in a sleeping bag
round town and bring blood-stained
sheets to the laundromat like it ain't
no thing on what I call crime in wild
white one day
Patrick chillin with his work homies
including the gay dude named Luis who
wants Patrick's nuts bad when he wanted
to pawn another investment banker who
Patrick is straight obsessed with this
cat got the looks the swagger and
managed the smallest account in town
official account palsy Patrick and be
like I was good markings halberstam
Patrick just go with it well who the
hell is Marcus as the book go on
Patrick's mind be slippin low and low
like when he had the video store you
start sweating balls and running his
mouth about how much he loved seeing a
woman get drilled to death in his
favorite flick full straight tweak it
later
Hatcher decide he gonna put that boy
Luis in the dirt so he rolled up on a
while he pissing right before he do Luis
break down and say I love you baby
when Luis try to get his mack on again
Pat like yo I don't usually get people
no warnings but hop off
Alma in yo ass Dodger get so bored with
his yuppie lifestyle of stacking chatter
doing lines and banging biddies and he
just go on killing homies left and right
I mean kids
Evelyn's neighbor a homeless dude and
old dude dogs owes his college
sweetheart
probably even put an axe through Paul
Owens dog damn one night he decided to
throw game at his secretary Jean this
girl been one the D just as bad as Luis
so she thrilled at the end of the night
she invited him up to her spot but he
liked my
girl I gotta go return some videotapes
she give him a little shriek anyway and
Patrick Starr feeling legit warm towards
her a detective dropped by Patrick's
office to ask him about paulin's
disappearance the Patrick shaked that
load off and dude don't suspect nothing
this just gets out of hand he kills a
little boy mohos does some redonkulous
stuff with a rack and even tricks Evelyn
and to eating a urinal cake with
chocolate on it so that it looks like
some fancy Godiva
but watching her eat it don't feel like
he thought it would so he breaks it off
right there after that he goes - his
[ __ ] fool murk a bunch of cops and even
blow up a damn cop car after dodging the
law I should roll up to his office break
down and leave a message for his lawyer
fasten up da his wagons deeds thing is
nothing ever happens after he confesses
so we drop in and Paul Owens digs
thinking he gonna find all the dead
bodies he stashed there but all he find
is a clean as apartment nice flowers and
a real estate agent who kicked his ass
out at dinner Jean tell Patrick how much
you love him and he thinking he should
accept her love and start feeling like
anything is possible later he running to
his lawyer
and asked him about that voicemail
confession but the lawyer like David yo
that's hilarious Patrick like David what
No - real kill Paula
you couldn't have killed Paul Owen I saw
him in London twice ten days ago and
Bateman man that dude is such a little
[ __ ] he could murder nobody not knowing
what the hell is going on Patrick jumps
in the can but gets jacked by the driver
who recognized him as the dude who
murdered his homeboy in the end Patrick
just chilling with his boys in the
uptown joint yappin bout bulls and
nothing has changed he say that
everything he's done is what being
Patrick means to him and that's it
when it comes to this crazy-ass book you
either think else's writing game is on
point
ours busted as hell some scholars saying
some postmodern classic others say it's
a bunch of violent Saxons book
what's your boy Sparky think well we'll
get to that later but first we gotta
cover a couple of things for one that
bull Bateman is an unreliable narrator I
mean some of this that supposedly
happened in this book it's just straight
stupid how are we supposed to believe
this dude just roll around town holding
bloody sheets without turning no heads
and when he go ham on the police at the
end who does catbag is Denzel Washington
one second it's an all-out manhunt in
the streets and the next chilling in his
office and everything seemed all good
is this cat trying to book the reader
and check this something real crazy
happens in a narrative when he switches
from first person the third person in
the middle of the damn sentence in an
adrenaline rush causing panting I can
only get a few blocks partly because of
panic mostly because of the blood brains
chunks of head covering the windshield
the cab rolling over fruit stands
smashing through a wall of glass the
body of the cashier thudding across the
hood Patrick tries to put the cab in
Reverse but nothing happens
so his punches showing us the action
movie version of his dubbed fantasy I
maybe not if it actually went down maybe
all this mess just proved that Patrick
losing his goddamn mind and then got no
grass but what's real and what ain't or
maybe it all did happen and just nobody
tripping on it all throughout this text
we see Bateman try to get people to see
him as the whack job he is but nobody
ever does I'm into old murders and
executions mostly it depends I shrug do
you like it
she asked unfazed um it depends why I
take a bite of sorbet well most guys I
know who work in mergers and
acquisitions don't really like it she
says that's not what I said
I say adding a fourth smile finishing my
J and B oh forget it we live in a
society where crazy-ass violence go down
on the rig and cuz of that people don't
even blink when they see messed up right
in front of them what they show is hell
do notice though is there when Bayman a
[ __ ]
slicing people to bits or whatever it's
been Paige is running his mouth by this
expensive swag stereo equipment threads
restaurants bedsheets business cards
where people get their haircuts I could
go on player people always going off
about how Americans are just stuck in an
endless cycle of consuming a bunch of
meaningless book the most banging that
Patrick reppin that to a tee but that
he'd do the same thing with people's he
even straight up eat some girl huh it's
like Patrick can't even tell the
difference between human beings and
objects eggs are lying in the corner in
my bedroom
a pair of girl shoes from Edward Susan
Bennett Island a hand with the thumb and
forefinger missing the new issue of
Vanity Fair splashed with someone's
blood and a cummerbund rich with gore
hell ain't no difference between people
neither Patrick always getting called
different names throughout the book and
when it happens he's just like whatever
it don't even matter when you're
swagging your status is all you are now
you can't really be legit individual you
feel me so look this book got some
pretty raw things to say about our
society and even though I dig the
message it ain't really my kind of thing
to be real with you this book is just
imploring the characters are paper-thin
and most of the book is just a bunch of
rambling blues yeah I get it the book
doing that on purpose to throw shade at
a society that's just as shallow as the
book itself but to this dog you got a
captivate your audience before you can
start preaching to Alice himself say it
best so I wrote a book that is all
service action no narrative no
characters the latch on to flat
endlessly repetitive I use comedy to get
at the absolute banality of the violence
of a perverse decade look it's a very
annoying book but that is how as a
writer I took in those years but hey if
this is your bankroll man different
strokes for different folks thanks for
kicking it with me today please
thanks for watching y'all don't forget
to subscribe so you can be sure to catch
all our videos there's lots more on the
way and you know what else is important
players showing off your skills and
there's no better way to do it than with
a fly website made with my boys at
Squarespace Squarespace is made it easy
for anyone to create a smoking website
and they're given all you will wear ball
is 10% off your first order when you use
the offer code thug notes they have all
the tools for you to show off just how
og you are you got to get over there and
check it out man cuz Squarespace is
hooking y'all up sign up today and
you'll get a free 14-day trial to test
it out why not and don't forget to use
the offer code thug notes and you'll get
10% off your order catch y'all next time
players peace